Hoje saí de casa com a minha namorada
para tentar achar os últimos doces de
Halloween eu Visitei todos os
supermercados que eu tenho aqui perto de
casa encontrei muita coisa inclusive um
bolo de abóbora achas que isto é bom
Espero que
sim a primeira loja onde nós fomos foi a
loja Teddy eu nunca tinha ido lá
infelizmente já não havia muito toque de
Halloween então acabamos só por
encontrar estas gomas são as gomas do
Drácula vem aqui com os dentes com
sangue eu não vou fazer a típica
avaliação de zer a 10 mas vou dizer se é
bom ou se não é bom Hum e pá é só mais
uma goma de morango é bom é um pouco
dura esta demora algum tempo a mascar
próxima loja que eu fui continente eu
não ia passar de todo pelo continente
porque eu sei que lá tem pouca coisa mas
como estávamos a caminho encontramos
isto sortido de gomas Mix com várias
gomas Ok vários saquinhos é tudo o mesmo
mais gomas mais gomas mais gomas temos
também as Oreo de Halloween a versão de
de Halloween que eu nunca experimentei
também estas aqui são bem conhecidas e
mais um pacote de gomas Monster Mix
dentaduras tem o olho do Vampiro tem o
cérebro do Vampiro tem tudo Vampiro aqui
vamos começar pelas gomas uh esta tem
ótimo
aspeto hum
hum é de laranja esta supera muito outra
esta supera de morango com certeza temos
um gato
preto
Hum que sabor é ISO Sava peixe ui eu sei
o que é Sabes o quê é chil chil Tool sim
aquelas gomas pretas que é isso chil é
pá não sei é uma planta sabe me sabe
peixe com pasta de dentes as gomas do do
gato são horríveis mas o resto é bom
estou ansioso para experimentar as Oreo
do Halloween Ok o recheio dela ah ela
tem todo um desenho Ok eu não sei se
conseguem ver mas tem assim o desenho de
uma teia de aranha o recheio é laranja
ah
aí
saba oro normal não há diferença aqui
diz que tem sabor de baunilha mas é
completamente igual aos normais vz
misteriosa tu quer experimentar uma quer
diz-me uma se não é igual à original é
mesmo igual a original não é é
literalmente igual não notei diferença
nenhuma é bom saco de gomas Mix mais uma
coisa do continente vamos ver se valeu a
pena tem um olho aqui vamos lá
ver hum ah um BO cusão é n hum não não
sabe igual a perna de pau é igual eu
acho que é tudo o mesmo sabor portanto
eu vou escolher Talvez o cérebro Vamos
provar este cérebro Hum ok esta é muito
boa porque a parte de cima tem outra
textura a parte de cima é uma Geleia e a
parte de baixo é goma eles deviam fazer
só com o cérebro Experimenta lá também
quero gel e caramelo de goma Pois é este
sabe meia caramelo ah próximo
Supermercado Aldi encontramos por acaso
o último stock de Halloween só existia
isto lá e vejam que coisa incrível Man
eu nunca vi um bolo de Halloween à venda
temos também estes biscoitos que T um
ótimo aspeto eu nunca vi isto também e
temos aqui a típica bolinha de chocolate
OK são olhos de chocolate Vamos provar
estes dois primeiro eu já vou atacar o
bolo bolinhas de chocolate são uns
olhinhos hum é o meu favorito Hum sabe a
kinder a ovo Kinder Experimenta lá sabe
mesmo a kinder a ovo Kinder ya é bom
Malta este Vale super a pena agora vamos
aos biscoitos de abóbora eu consigo mais
ou menos imaginar o sabor disto não é
crocante Hum sabe chocolate e a parte de
cima é estaladiça vê se tem uma camada
zinha de Açúcar muito bom muito bom ya
bolacha lá dentro é de canela ou
qualquer coisa de canela achas uhum ou
de gengibre eu acho que é de gengibre
agora vamos ao verdadeiro habitualmente
Isto é vendido no Natal mas eu nunca vi
um de
Halloween são 750 g de bolo Isto é quase
1 kg de bolo mal mal Tecnicamente tem um
recheio de abóbora ali dentro
hum ser a mesma
abóbora Calma eu vou Fate aqui deste
lado que é para vocês conseguirem ver
Ei eu acho que isto vai ser
seco ó pá isto parece seco ó pá isto
parece um bocado de bolo com areia Tem
recheio aqui mas é pouquíssimo aqui em
cima aqui em cima aqui em cima ainda tem
recheio hum Calma calma preciso de tempo
preciso de tempo
o recheio é muito bom hum é pena ter
pouco aqui bem no centro ele já é
molinho já é úmido aqui por fora tá
muito seco tá muito seco e tem uma
textura péssima mas dentro lá no meio tá
incrivelmente bom eu vou tentar abrir o
bolo todo e vamos ver se lá dentro tem
mais recheio
Ah o recheio é só mesmo ali dentro
porque aqui em cima depois tem pequenas
pepitas de abóbora e pá eu acho que não
vale a pena agora vendo assim o bolo
todo por dentro acho que não vale a pena
em comparação ao que está aqui é isto é
esta imagem nada a ver nada a ver
próxima loja é uma que eu costumo muito
frequentar Lidl estes olhos eu adoro já
provei Marshmallows um chocolate eu não
sei se é de leite mas vamos provar e um
caixão Não faço ideia do que vem aqui
dentro eu nem olhei bem a embalagem
estes olhos aqui são incríveis maltas
Olha lá é bem
viscoso hum iso é muito bom hum esqueci
dist isto tem recheio is Tem recheio
pois este é um bocado ácido pois aqui
diz os que eu tinha provado não eram
ácidos mas este é bom
também caraças
susto gasi com o olho eu já I fazer
aquela manobra sei lá Já ias apertar
aqui o peito sim temos estes
Marshmallows e pá eu não sou muito fã de
Marshmallows porque eu acho que seca
muito a boca é demasiado doce
marshmallow eu acho que é 100% açúcar
portanto eu não sei se vou gostar disto
Olha aí são Fantasminhas
uh são bonitos a anec Adora os
Marshmallows
adoro estes aqui eu acho que são
melhores Porque como são mais pequenos
come-se bem é bom vamos lá ali no Lidl
também tínhamos este caixão E pelo que
eu estou a ver isto é mais ou menos um
sortido Uh que louco vem um olho aqui
dentro vem este olho de chocolate e vem
esqueletos de chocolate vários
esqueletos de chocolate vamos lá isto
deve ser o chocolate de
leite Uhum é bom é bom come-se Pá Não
Vou Comer tudo senão é muito açúcar e
este chocolate aqui que também tinha lá
deve ser exatamente o mesmo chocolate
mas n outro packaging só um pouquinho
Malta senão é o chocolate é o mesmo
próxima loja mercadona lá tinha imensa
coisa mas também era muito à base de
gomas e eu já me cansei de gomas as
coisas mais diferenciadas que eu
encontrei foram estas temos o
chupa-chupa do Shrek temos aqui um
chupa-chupa do Drácula temos uma uma
mochila com muita coisa aqui dentro não
sei o que é e temos aqui mais um pacote
pois de gomas eu disse que tentei evitar
as gomas e acabei por comprar isso não é
o Shrek B Isto é o Shrek não é nada isso
for ser tipo um franken Style meio
Zombie eu não sei se quero comer isto dá
vontade de dar uma trinca e ao mesmo
tempo
não isto parecia que ia ser mais doce do
que os Marshmallows eu não consigo comer
mais isto tu não queres dar uma trinca
quero é bom mas mas é muito açúcar para
mim Malta vamos ao chupa chupa do
Drácula este eu Talvez goste mais porque
é de chocolate leite tem os dentes
vermelhos au qu par o dente fogo hum foi
exatamente o mesmo sabor do que aqueles
skeletons de chocolate só muda mesmo o
marketing né agora só para acabar com as
gomas porque eu já estou farto de gomas
Com certeza que tem sabor a laranja
neste caso tem uma abóbora que é muito
parecida às outras gomas que nós comemos
eu acho que é a mesma goma Pois é a
mesma marca ya três pacotes de gomas eu
pensei que eram mais fui escamado
esqueleto Azul melões e temos estas
Estas são Um clássico devem ser muito
boas hum é que esta é molinha esta é
muito boa apesar de ser muito doce bo é
é muito boa esta vamos agora aos melões
laranjas sab melão inclusive mas aqui
diz com o que é que é o
Malta que é do Brasil atenção
porque em Portugal é outra coisa OK
eu sei que tem muita gente aí do do
Brasil a ver Normalmente quando diz
é porque é ácido mas isto não é ácido e
eu não sinto a em mim temho que ir
escovar os dentes próxima goma Azul L
apareceu uma goma da Marvel deixa eu ver
hum esta é totalmente molinha e esta é
mais dura o sabor é exatamente o mesmo
eu acho que o rei do Halloween é mesmo o
achan porque lá tinha muita variedade
tinha muita coisa diferente que eu nunca
vi inclusive este caixão com mix de de
gomas e sei lá o que é que vem aqui
dentro tem uma abóbora também com um
packaging incrível com mais doces dentro
tem também este con tem esta abóbora não
sei o que tem temos aqui este Mix super
comum também vamos ver se tem alguma
coisa interessante vamos lá abrir o
caixa no Vampiro 3 2 1 ó Olha tem muita
coisa aqui temos dois
chupas temos dois finis Marshmallows eu
acho mais outro temos duas línguas
pastilha elástica eu acho chama-se
Booster mini Estou curioso com este e
temos uns Jelly Bears uns ursinhos
reparem que tem aqui um jogo até tem
aqui um labirinto com um jogo do Vampiro
Malta eu não vou experimentar estes
doces todos Isto é um sortido portanto
eu vou escolher só um já sei o que é
isto Ok isto parece-me ser o como é que
se chama sabes as gorila não é as gorila
eram sugos e eu não vou comer porque
demasiado açúcar já comi
muito estas bolinhas de ténis são muito
boas tem um recheio muito bom por dentro
tem as de melancia tem mais tem outros
com recheio tem muitos finos aqui dentro
incrível tem as gominhas também dos
ursos pá eu acho que vale a pena Malta
eu não vou experimentar Porque isto é
tudo da fi eu já sei mais ao menos o
sabor não sei quanto custou mas este
Vale super a pena tem a mesma coisa aqui
dentro vamos ver
ah ok é parecido o conteúdo é parecido
tem mais chupas a chupa mais chupas mais
chupas mais gomas de abóbora gomas bem
isto não acaba este compensa
Marshmallows bem vamos meter isto aqui
de lado temos mais coisas para ver eu
também adorei este packaging tá incrível
é uma abóboras uma caixa muito bonita ah
pacotes de
gomas dois pacotes de gomas e temos aqui
também
mais um con
da Ok Marshmallows temos mais um chupa
chupa de Emoções temos mais uma lngua
temos mais um os os de goma est curioso
só para provar esta goma que eu acho que
nunca comi é boa
esta sabe mesmo eu tenho noho para coisa
eu ol eu olho para as coisas e se Sabor
em termos de quantidade o em termos de
qualidade
o Y